على كل من القاهره ينضم الينا استاذ
الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره عباس
الشرقاوي اهلا بك دكتور عباس معانا في
الصباح العربيه الكثير من الاشاعات حامت
حول زلزال تركيا وسوريا نبدا بابرزها اولا
استخدام اسلحه لاحداث زلازل اصطناعيه بهدف
احداث التعديل المجال المغناطيسي للارض
جيولوجيا الى امادا هذا منطقي
صباح الخير
يعني اذا تحدثنا عن الزلزال وان يكون
العمل صناعي هذا الزلزال قوي للغايه
وشدته بتصل الى حوالي الف قنبله نوويه من
قنابل هيروشيما وبالتالي لو كان هذا عمل
صناعي يبقى اذا قنبله او اثنين او عشره
لكن لما يبقى الف قنبله وهذا الزلزال
الضخم اللي حصل سته فبراير ادى الى ان
الكتله الاناضليه اللي هي بطول 1300 كيلو
متر وعرض 500 كيلو ان تندفع اتجاه البحر
المتوسط حوالي 8 كيلومتر فاذا القوه هائله
اكبر دكتور الزلزال اكبر من اي قنبله
بشريه
الف مره اكبر يعني اكبر من هيروشيما الف
مره وايضا يعني كميه المتفجرات المطلوبه
لاحداث هذه الطاقه تعادل 50 مليون طن
متفكره